so stress and anxiety
what
what is that and can it be leveraged for
good
absolutely stressing luke whether or not
you get into a cold ice bath or a hot
sauna so hot you want to get out or
you
get hit square in the face with
something over text that you really
didn't want to hear or see
it's adrenaline it's just adrenaline and
so your subjective readout of that and
what it means is really important and
you can just channel that well you can
if you if you
agree with the following statement which
i do and many people do because the data
support it which is ali chrom's
statement not mine which is she directs
the mind body lab at stanford she's
brilliant by the way um brilliant
harvard trained yell trained
trained licensed clinical psychologists
also tenured professors you know she's a
uh uh olympian uh no excuse me a
division one athlete in gymnastics and
uh martial arts and her dad um is a
longtime martial arts trainer he's done
work with special forces and he's an
amazing human being and very humble very
kind lovely woman and professor
scientist
she says anything that you do and
experience but especially stress
is the consequence of that thing and
what you believe about that thing
and so if you consume a lot of
information about the powers of
stressful states to bring out your best
you will perform better if you consume a
lot of information about the power of
stress to [ __ ] you you will perform
worse
there's absolutely no question the data
are striking and this is not growth
mindset this is just simply what sorts
of in what do you believe about stress
based on the
dominant knowledge that you're consuming
about it so that's why it's fun to watch
david
goggins here we go again david or jocko
or or joe or someone put where cam
haines you know put out this information
about or ryan hall who ran for stanford
and then now is like into the power
lifting thing and running you know
and there are others too of course
when you
start to consume a lot of that
information it's not just inspiring it
actually changes your perception of what
your own stressful states mean
they
you can actually get better from stress
if you're in the ocean of knowledge that
stress grows you if you're in the ocean
of living in the ocean of knowledge i
was thinking like a pool in the summer
you got the kiddie pool the kids all
peeing in it presumably you got the
diving thing you got the high dive and
all that if you believe that
the experience of belly flopping off the
high dive is going to make you a better
diver
in some sense it at least in this
analogy it will
whereas if you feel that it's just the
most embarrassing thing ever and it's
going to [ __ ] your ability to get out
and dive in front of anybody ever again
well you're you're right about that too
yeah we uh actually talk with carl about
depression all those kinds of things
that there there could be
these
what are commonly seen as negative
journeys they could be
when reframed can be used you know one
of the reasons i enjoy our friendship so
much is that you bring this russian
thing
you know which i don't really understand
it at a deep level how could i i'm not
russian but um
but this mindset like that there's pain
in life when i watched that uh hedgehog
in the fog
cartoon i thought no wonder russians
call it the way they do this is the most
it's so sad it's beautiful and savage so
sad whereas out here it's like sesame
street and you know my mother would not
let me watch sesame street when i was a
kid yes she thought it was too chaotic
she was too chaotic too chaotic she was
like it's too chaotic too many things
going on captain kangaroo we were
allowed and then mr rogers we were
allowed i never really liked shows i
like doing things in outside in the in
the yard um i was trying to trap all the
animals i didn't want to watch stuff on
tv but you know hedgehog in the fog is
enough to turn any kid into a thinker
and a philosopher and a poet
you